>> WAS THAT A MAN OR A
WOMAN?
BECAUSE HE NEEDS A HAIR CUT
MORE THAN I DO.
I COULDN'T TELL.
HE NEEDS A HAIR CUT.
>> Greg: THAT'S OUR DONALD.
LAST NIGHT'S RALLY WAS
NOTHING NEW.
THE CROWD LOFERRED HIM.
THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HATE
HIM WILL JUST HATE HIM MORE.
THE MEDIA PATS ITSELF ON THE
HEAD FOR NOT COVERING IT
WHILE SECRETLY WATCHING FOX
NEWS TOO BAD THEY TOTALLY
MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CALL HIM HITLER.
SO FOR THE BIAS ELM PAIRED
SO FOR THE BIAS ELM PA IED
SO FOR THE BIAS ELM PA IMPAIRED
HERE IS NEWS.
HE GOT REMAINS OF 200 U.S.
SOLDIERS BACK FROM NORTH
KOREA WEEK AFTER ISSUE WAS
RAISE.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
HELPING WOMEN AND MEN.
OUR G.D.P. CLIMBS HIGHER.
SO, IF HE A MONSTER, HE
MIGHT BE THE WORST MONSTER
EVER.
MEANING NOT A MONSTER AT
ALL.
THAT'S WHY OPTIMISM IS HIGH.
95% OF MANUFACTURERS HAVE A
POSITIVE COMPANY OUTLOOK.
IT'S GOOD NEWS.
EVEN IF THE ELITES DENY IT.
AND ABOUT THOSE ELITES.
>> DO YOU EVER NOTICE THEY
ALWAYS CALL THE OTHER SIDE,
THE ELITE.
WHY ARE THEY ELITE?
I HAVE A MUCH BETTER
APARTMENT THAN THEY DO.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I'M SMARTER THAN THEY ARE.
I'M RICHER THAN THEY ARE.
I BECAME PRESIDENT AND THEY
DIDN'T.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
GREATEST, SMARTEST, MOST
LOYAL, BEST PEOPLE ON EARTH,
THE DEPLORABLES.
REMEMBER THAT?
>> Greg: THAT'S KEY.
BRAG SOMETHING NEVER
APPEALING BUT IS HE NOT
WRONG.
THAT BY WEALTH HE IS AN
ELITIST, YET, HE IS STILL
EMBRACED BY WORKING CLASSES.
NO WONDER THE DENIROS, UPON
DOES ALL UNRALPH, TRUMP IS
RICHER THAN THEM ALL BUT
CLOSER TO THE STREET THAN
THEY ARE.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
THE ANSWER IS HE MAKES
PROMISES AND FIGHTS TO KEEP
THEM.
BESIDES FOR YOU DEPLORABLES
AT THE RALLY THE OUTRAGE
CELEBRITY CLASS WILL ALWAYS
DEEM YOU TO BE THE UNCOOL
KIDS.
TRUMP DEFENDS YOU AGAINST
THE JERKS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WEALTH OR
APARTMENTS.
IT'S ABOUT SPEAKING UP FOR
PEOPLE THAT THE MEDIA
CELEBRITY COMPLEX SNICKERS
AT.
AND IT'S WHY WHEN EVERYTHING
SEEMS TO BE WORKING OUT
THOSE SNICKERS SEEM TRULY
FROM MARS.
[LAUGHTER]
DID YOU LIKE THAT, DANA?
>> Dana: YEAH AND A MILKY
WAY.
>> Greg: DO YOU LIKE THOSE
PUNS.
IS DONALD TRUMP A BIT LIKE
YOUR RICH UNCLE TELLING --
WHY CAN'T YOUR BUDDY GET A
HAIR CUT?
>> Dana: I GREW UP IN
WYOMING WHERE TIGHT SHORT
HAIR CUT.
MY AUNT DONNA IS THE ONE WHO
DOES THE HAIRCUTS IN THE
KITCHEN EVERY COUPLE WEEKS
THERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS THINKING
ABOUT TODAY.
I WAS TRYING TO THINK ONE
OTHER PERSON WHO HAD THIS
ABILITY SOMEONE WHO WAS
SUCCESSFUL, WEALTHY,
CELEBRITY.
STILL CONSIDERED BLUE
COLLAR.
>> Greg: ME.
>> Dana: I CAME UP WITH
CLINTON EASTWOOD.
I THINK IT'S PARTLY BECAUSE
OF THE ART THAT HE CHOSE.
THE WAY HE CHOSE TO -- THE
MOVIES HE DIRECTED.
YOU HOW HE ACTED AND THINGS
HE DID.
THERE IS NOT MANY OTHERS.
>> Greg: HE SPEAKS THE
LANGUAGE, JESSE.
IT'S LIKE BUT I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE HAIR CUT THING.
>> Jesse: SURE.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE THE HAIR
CUT THING IS BEING
PRESENTABLE FOR A JOB.
THAT'S HOW A SALESMAN LIKE
GET A HAIR CUT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: CLEAN IT UP,
WATTERS.
HE IS ALSO A MAN'S MAN.
YOU SPEAK ABOUT THESE MAN
BUNS AND YOU CAN MOCK A MAN
BUN NOW.
>> Kimberly: GREG DOES.
>> Jesse: STILL CAN DO THAT
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO TALK
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE'S
APPEARANCE BECAUSE THEY MAY
BE ACCUSED OF BEING
INSENSITIVE.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NEVER BEEN
AFRAID OF BEING CALLED
INSENSITIVE.
LIKE THE COMMON MAN FOR A
FREE REASONS.
HE HAS DEALT WITH
CONTRACTORS ALL MY LIFE.
CAN I SMELL A CONTRACTOR.
IT'S TRUE.
AS A REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER
YOU DEAL WITH THE PIPE
FITTERS, THE MASONS, THE
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERS AND HE
IS GREAT AT THAT.
HE ALSO EATS FAST FOOD.
NOT FOR A PHOTO OP. BECAUSE
HE ACTUALLY LIKES IT.
>> Kimberly: IS HE LIKE US.
JESS IN A BRASH STYLE THAT
CONNECTS WITH THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
TO BE HONEST, IS HE THAT
ASPIRATIONAL CELEBRITY.
FOR MANY GENERATIONS PEOPLE
IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
LOOKED UP TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY LIKE THE WOMEN HE WAS
AROUND.
THEY LIKED THE PLANES.
THEY LIKED THE STYLE.
THEY LIKED THE JETS.
IF YOU WANT TO BECOME RICH
IN AMERICA, YOU YOU WANTED
TO BE LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
LET'S NOT FORGET BEFORE HE
RAN FOR PRESIDENT ATHLETES
WANTED TO LIVE IN TRUMP
TOWER.
ALL THE REAL ESTATE GUYS
THEY WANTED SOME, YOU KNOW,
TEE TIMES AT HIS GOLF CLUBS.
>> Greg: MOST CITED
CELEBRITY IN RAP MUSIC.
JESS ANY WANTED A PIECE OF
ACTION.
THIS GUY WAS IT.
THE MINUTE HE RUNS FOR
PRESIDENT HE IS HITLER.
>> Greg: THIS TRUMP DEALS
WITH MASONS NOT FREE MASON.
LIKE THE ELITE ESTABLISHMENT
VS. THE EVERY DAY MAN.
>> Dana: MY GRANDFATHER ON
MY MOM'S SIDE.
RAWLINGS, WYOMING.
>> Greg: JUAN, I KNOW YOU
LOVED THAT RALLY.
YOU RECORDED IT AND PLAYED
IT FIVE TIMES.
>> Juan: THE QUESTION IS THE
APARTMENT.
HIS APARTMENT IS BETTER THAN
THEIR APARTMENT.
NOT ONLY BETTER, SMARTER,
BETTER APARTMENT.
OH MY GOD YOU THINK ABOUT A
PETTY PERSON MAKES
EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM.
>> Greg: IS HE BEING FUNNY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK HE IS
BEING FUNNY, THAT'S HIM.
I GOT A BETTER APARTMENT SO
HOW COME I'M NOT ELITE?
>> Kimberly: YOU TAKE
EVERYTHING SO LITERALLY.
>> Juan: HE WAS TRYING TO
SAY THAT HE -- HE COULD BE
IN THAT GROUP BUT YOU LOVE
ME AND I LOVE YOU.
THAT'S WHAT I GOT OUT OF IT.
>> Juan: NO, NO, NO.
I WILL TELL WHAT YOU IT WAS.
>> Greg: IT WASN'T INSULTING
TO ANYBODY.
>> Juan: WORTHY OF MOCKERY.
MY APARTMENT IS BIGGER THAN
YOURS, MY BUTTON IS BIGGER
THAN YOURS.
THIS IS HOW HE TALKS.
HOW HE RELATES TO PEOPLE
THESE OTHER CELEBRITIES
DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
THE WORKING MAN.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU
SOMETHING, I'M NOT SURE HE
HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
WORKING MAN ON SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM PARENTS.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE WORKING MAN.
WHAT HE DOES IS.
>> Greg: HE BROUGHT THEM
TOGETHER NOW.
>> Juan: HOT BUTTON ISSUES
AND FEAR.
YOU CAN HATE HILLARY
CLINTON.
HE HAD THE CROWD LAST NIGHT
CHANTING LOCK HER UP.
HE CAN SAY THINGS LIKE GO
HOME TO YOUR MOM TO THIS
GUY.
WHY DON'T YOU GET A HAIR
CUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A MAN
OR A WOMAN.
>> Greg: THAT'S A TERRIBLE
IMPRESSION, JUAN.
>> Juan: HE HATES ON
CLINTON.
HE HATES ON EVERYBODY THEN
HE SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
MAYBE WHOSE HISPANICS, THEY
ARE TERRIBLE, TOO.
>> Greg: WHAT'S THAT BEEN
HISPANICS?
I MISSED THAT I THINK HE
MEANT MS-13.
>> Greg: HIS APPEAL IS BASED
ON HATEFUL LANGUAGE AND HE
APPEALS TO THE WORSE.
>> Greg: SO WE'RE ALL BAD
PEOPLE.
KIMBERLY?
>> Kimberly: I THINK AMERICA
IS GREAT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
SAYING THAT LAST NIGHT WHAT
AN INCREDIBLE COUNTRY AND
SUPPORTERS AND TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING.
HE HAS ACTUALLY FOLLOWED
THROUGH AND HAD TREMENDOUS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS LIKE WE
REITERATED NUMEROUS TIMES ON
THIS SHOW.
I DON'T KNOW, FOR MYSELF IN
TERMS OF AS A PUERTO RICAN
WOMAN AND LOOKING AT OTHER
MINORITIES.
QUITE PLEASED THE NUMBERS
ARE GOING UP IN TERMS OF
THEIR FAVORABILITY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, YES.
AND YOU SEE KEY NUMBERS
GOING DOWN, UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHY WOULDN'T SOMEBODY BE
HAPPY ABOUT THAT?
LOWER UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
WOMEN, FOR MINORITIES.
FOR HISPANICS, FOR BLACKS.
ISIS GONE.
WE HAVE GOT RECORD JOB
NUMBERS.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY'S
APARTMENT IS BETTER THAN
YOURS.
>> Juan: I BET IT IS.
HE NOT ONLY WAS ATTACKING
PELOSI AND CLINTON.
HE THEN GOES AFTER JOHN